[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і сьогодні
у нас буде урок письма, тож, будь ласка,
приготуйтеся з олівцями для штанів та
підручниками, і давайте почнемо добре
писати надзвичайно важливо, оскільки вам потрібно
буде щось зробити  писати під час
моделі зовнішнього іспиту, де ви повинні будете
писати власні електронні листи та спілкуватися
з іншими людьми за допомогою листів або дописів
або щось, що ви повинні написати, і
сьогодні ми збираємося написати листа
другу, це неформальний лист, тому  і
тому це трохи простіше,
ніж офіційне написання розпочати і
подивіться на фрази. Це
фрази, які ви використовуєте, щоб почати і закінчити
свій лист, давайте переглянемо їх,
тому першим, як усе йде
, передай привіт вашій родині  і друзі
мають почути від вас незабаром вибачте,
я не написав раніше, я був у
відпустці, подбайте, будь ласка, напишіть швидше,
дякую за ваш лист і розповісти мені
всі ваші новини, було приємно почути від
вас інше  r день добре, що фрази
змішані між собою деякі з них
належать початку деякі з них належать до
кінця останнього подивіться на
хвилинку і вирішите, які фрази мають
йти на початку, а які фрази
мають йти в кінці
добре, хлопці  якщо ви готові перевірити,
давайте подивимося, тож ось фрази для
початку листа, як усе йде
після цієї фрази, ви можете сказати добре, я
добре, я сподіваюся, що ви теж добре,
дякую за ваш лист і розповісти мені
всі новини після цього  фразу, яку ти можеш
розповісти про те, що сталося у
твоєму житті, або дати свою реакцію на
новину, яку ти зашкодив, я фактично прочитаю
наступну, вибачте, я не написав раніше.
Я був у відпустці, якщо це було
давно  ви відповіли на електронну
пошту або ви повинні сказати вибачення та
пояснили причину, чому причини можуть бути
різними, можливо, ви готувались
до іспитів або ви були зайняті,
допомагаючи батькам у саду, чи щось
інше, що
ця людина була у відпустці, і він  каже,
що я був у відпустці, остання
фраза для початку це було
чудово почути від вас днями
знову ви відреагували на лист своєї
подруги тітки замість того, щоб це було чудово, ви
можете використовувати це було дивно це було чудово  це
було просто неймовірно, я був такий щасливий, я кажу, що
насправді я був дуже радий почути від
вас днями або було дивно отримати
від вас листа, якщо ви хочете бути більш
жалюгідними, добре, тоді давайте фрази, щоб
закінчити лист і  закінчуйте лист,
ми можемо використовувати такі фрази, як сподіваюся почути
від вас незабаром гарна фраза бережіть, і в
ці дні ми додаємо бережіть себе та
вимийте руки,
тоді ви зможете привітатися зі своєю
сім'єю та друзями привітати свого
улюбленого вчителя привітатися  твої
двоюрідні брати
вітаються з твоєю бабусею, кому ти
хочеш привітатися, добре, я останній,
будь ласка, повертайся швидше, звичайно, я хочу
отримати набагато швидше я хочу отримати
повідомлення швидше, і я б написав
його, будь ласка, напишіть назад  скоро гаразд,
тож це були фрази  щоб розпочати
та закінчити листа, давайте перейдемо далі,
це лист, і його написав
Денні, і він написаний Сабріні, а тепер
давайте подивимося на цей лист, давайте
прочитаємо його та давайте обговоримо, тож
, будь ласка, слідкуйте за мною в  читаючи дякую
за твій лист, було приємно почути
від тебе, що ти попросив мене розповісти тобі про
мій улюблений день тижня, а це,
безперечно, п’ятниця, одна з причин, чому я люблю
п’ятницю, це те, що у мене є мої улюблені
предмети у школі фізкультура, а
хімія – це чудово, тому що  ми проводимо
експерименти в науковій лабораторії, а наш
викладач Mr.  Кінг такий смішний
у фізкультурі, ми зазвичай граємо в баскетбол, який
є моїм улюбленим видом спорту. Я добре в цьому,
тому що я досить високий, наша команда зазвичай
виграє, у нас також французька мова по п'ятницях,
що насправді є моїм найменш улюбленим
предметом, але після цього у нас є ІКТ  що
зараз набагато цікавіше
я створюю веб-сторінку для нашої
баскетбольної команди після школи я гуляю
з друзями, а потім увечері
граю у футбол у Спортивному центрі в
п'ятницю ввечері ми іноді ходимо до
когось на вечірку
або щоб подивитися DVD,
ми можемо трохи розслабитися в п'ятницю ввечері,
тому що в суботу немає школи,
розкажіть мені про свій улюблений день у своєму
наступному листі, сподіваюся скоро почути від вас,
люблю Денні, який чудовий лист, хлопці, так,
мені дуже сподобалося читати його там  Є
кілька причин, чому мені сподобалося читати,
перш за все, основна причина полягає в тому, що
абзаци подивіться лист
містить один два три чотири абзаци,
будь ласка, знайте, що використовуйте їх у своєму
письмі, вони допоможуть вам розрізнити
інформацію, і легше читати
великі твори, якщо в них є абзаци,
давайте поглянемо на
початок листа, в ньому зазначено, дорога Сабріна, введіть
будь-яке інше ім'я, і у вас є по
аток, дорога Сабріна, дорога Мері, дорогий Дж
н, дорога Катя, хто б ви не пи
али, тоді ви  повинен бути вдячним і
зазвичай говорив «дякую» за твій лист
під вказівкою причини
вашого письма, тому ваш друг попросив вас
написати про ваш улюблений день
тижня, а Денні сказав, що це була п’ятниця,
наступний абзац більше, ніж
перший, а потім вступний
абзац розповідає нам першу причину, чому
він віддає перевагу п'ятниці, тому він згадує свої
улюблені предмети, а потім у великому
абзаці, третій, він продовжує
наводити інші причини любити п'ятницю,
і я думаю, що є одна універсальна
причина для всіх  школярі
в усьому світі люблять п'ятничних хлопців, і
найкраща причина, звичайно, полягає в тому, що
по суботах немає школи, повірте,
вчителі відчувають себе  Так само ми
всі
дуже щасливі по п'ятницях, тому що ми
також з нетерпінням чекаємо закінчення вихідних, добре,
і найменший абзац номер чотири
- це ваше запитання до вашого друга, воно може
бути дуже коротким, вам не потрібно отримувати
багато  інформацію в цьому, тому
що ви задаєте питання і хочете, щоб
ваш друг відповів вам, можливо, я
додам щось, наприклад, напишіть мені найближчим часом або
я передам привіт вашим батькам або я сподіваюся
почути від вас одного дня або навіть я сподіваюся
побачити  ти одного дня, і, можливо, замість
любові я б писав обійми та поцілунки або з
найкращими побажаннями, що також цікаво
в неформальному написанні листів
до друга, це те, що ви можете використовувати
скорочення, вам не потрібно писати, чи
не ви можете зробити це, не  вам не потрібно
писати, це не так, це
все хороші скорочення, крім того, ви можете
використовувати gonna замість того, щоб піти або wanna
замість одного двох, а іноді, коли
ви пишете електронні листи своїм друзям або коли
ви розмовляєте  для них ви можете використовувати емодзі та
щось на кшталт t  але, звичайно, під
час ЗНО ви не
зможете використовувати всі ці смішні речі,
на жаль, добре, ми можемо піти далі, і
давайте подивимося на запитання в тексті, тому
перевірте своє розуміння, як ви
отримали останнє, чи ви все зрозуміли правильно,
щоб  перше речення Денні — учень середньої
школи, це саме ось
старшокласник, якого він сказав у своєму
листі, що він незвично вивчає ІКТ ІКТ
— це для
старшокласників, а також хімія, тоді
Денні вважає п'ятницю найкращим
днем тижня  безперечно, він каже добре, він каже, що
мій улюблений день тижня добре,
безумовно, п'ятниця, безумовно, означає, що
він на 100% впевнений, тому твердження
правильне, потім приходить Денні любить французьку чи
ви пам'ятаєте в текстурі Hassad у нас
також є французька та п'ятниця, що
насправді для мене найменше  улюблений предмет
найменш улюблений предмет означає, що йому
зовсім не подобається цей предмет, він його
переносить, але він його не любить,
тому твердження є помилковим.  t
заява в п'ятницю
Денні має ІКТ клас перед її французьким
класом добре hmm давайте подивимося,
так ІКТ, який є набагато цікавішим,
ніж французький клас немає французьких дівчат у класі
до ІКТ, тому твердження неправильне
наступний
Mr.  Кінг – вчитель фізкультури Mr.  Король
давайте знайдемо в тексті
mr.  Король Mr.  Кінг – вчитель хімії,
тому твердження невірне, що
він не вчитель фізкультури.
тож ось твердження вірні та
невірні, я сподіваюся, що ви зробили їх правильно,
давайте продовжимо розглянути ось
запитання та абзаци,
будь ласка, зіставте запитання з
параграфами, давайте подивимося добре, тож давайте
спочатку розглянемо запитання,
перше запитання чому  ти любиш
літо, тож ти маєш знайти
причину наступного, який твій улюблений вид спорту,
тож у цьому параграфі йдеться про спорт,
який твій улюблений
предмет у школі привіт і який твій
найменш улюблений предмет у школі
найменш улюблений предмет означає предмет,
який ти любиш?  Не подобається добре,
а потім приходить, хто твій улюблений вчитель
у школі, чи є у тебе улюблений
вчитель і чим ти зазвичай займаєшся
на вихідних, а тепер приділи хвилинку та
подивись  h абзаци, тоді ми порівняємо
їх усі разом
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ви готові, давайте подивимося, тож
перше запитання, який абзац є
найкращим варіантом для нього, чому вам подобається
літо, і правильна відповідь: B, давайте
прочитаємо  параграф Мені це подобається, тому що я
зазвичай ходжу на пляж, а школи немає.
Я люблю плавати в морі та
грати в пляжний волейбол, зараз це, безумовно,
найкращий сезон
тому що я зазвичай ходжу в гори
і ходжу туди в похід, і, звісно
, немає школи, і в мене довгі ка
ікули, це, безперечно, один з найкращих се
онів, добре, давайте пр
довжуємо, давайте прочитаємо друге питання і поєднаємо його з п
раграфом, щоб другий  Питання в тому,
який ваш улюблений вид спорту і який він
відповідає параграфу ІІ, давайте прочитаємо
параграф Я люблю їх усіх, але я граю в
теніс двічі на тиждень у школі, а також
після школи по п’ятницях. Зараз я добре вмію
, хлопці, попередньо  як правило,
ви відповідаєте на це запитання, тож
який ваш улюблений вид спорту, якби я
відповів, я б сказав, що я не можу сказати, що мені
подобаються всі види спорту, я люблю змагальні
види спорту і мені подобаються види спорту з м’ячем,
можливо, мій улюблений баскетбол,
але я не граю  зазвичай
добре, подумайте про свої відповіді,
потім з’являється запитання номер 3, який
ваш улюблений предмет у школі і він
відповідає параграфу F, давайте прочитаємо параграф
F, безумовно, мистецтво.
я хотів би
бути дизайнером, добре, якби мені поставили
таке питання давно, коли я
була школяркою, я б точно відповіла
так, тому на питання, який твій
улюблений предмет у школі, я б сказав, що
безперечно англійська я добре володію англійською
і я проводжу весь свій вільний час, дивлячись
англійські фільми та проводячи уроки з
моїм приватним учителем Я сподіваюся, що одного дня
я стану чудовим вчителем англійської мови,
це було б моєю відповіддю,
які ваші відповіді я впевнений, що
серед вас  є люди, які люблять
різні предмети,
можливо, літературу, можливо, математику, можливо,
хімію, можливо, ІКТ, а чому б не спорт
і фізкультуру, запитання номер чотири, який ваш
найменш улюблений предмет у школі і він
відповідає параграфу D, подивимося, давайте прочитаємо
параграф D, мабуть, драма, я просто не
відчуваю  комфортно грати або виступати
перед іншими людьми, але мені подобається
спостерігати за своїми друзями раніше на сцені, якби мені
задали таке питання, я думаю, що
я б сказав, що хімія Мені не подобалася
хімія, коли я був у школі, але
насправді я дуже шкодую, що я  не
вивчив його добре, тому що зараз це виглядає
як дуже цікавий предмет, коли
я бачу, як
діти його вивчають, добре, давайте перейдемо далі,
тому наступне питання: хто ваш улюблений
вчитель у школі, і він відповідає
параграфу C, тож ми маємо  ось це
важко мені подобається Mr.  Каллі
він викладає мистецтво, він добрий креативний і
завжди показує нам нових художників і способи
створювати мистецтво, він справді класний, гарний Я сподіваюся,
що у вас є улюблені вчителі,
ваші улюблені вчителі можуть стати вашими
наставниками, і вони можуть стати вашими друзями,
вчитель може не знати всього
ми не працюємо з енциклопедіями, але ми
можемо показати вам шлях, куди ви можете йти,
і ми можемо показати вам, як ви можете розвинути
свої здібності та творчі здібності. Я дуже
вдячний своїй вчительці літератури, яку я
мав у школі, і вона була тим, хто
показав  мені, наскільки яскравою та різноманітною
може бути література, давайте перейдемо до
останнього питання, що ти зазвичай робиш
на вихідних, і, звичайно, воно відповідає
параграфу а, і там сказано, що я не дуже
люблю проводити час зі своєю сім’єю, і ми
маємо великий обід  разом у неділю я
іноді ходжу по магазинах з друзями в
суботу або відвідую бабусю та дідуся
насправді, ця неділя виглядає майже у
мене в моїй родині, ми також добре
обідаємо разом, але ми ніколи не пішли
б  pping по неділях Я буду ходити за покупками
по суботах і відвідуватиму своїх сватів
або своїх дітей, бабусю та дідуся, так що майже
так само приємно, відповідаючи на ці
запитання, ви майже отримали макет для
свого листа, якщо відповісте на ці
запитання, використовуючи три, чотири або навіть
два  речення, яких буде достатньо для
гарної
гідної літери під час тесту
чи будь-якої іншої ситуації у вашому
житті, іноді, як викладачі, ми бачимо
такі речення у вашій скриньці для копій, ми бачимо,
що ви іноді не використовуєте великі
літери або ви пропускаєте коми  або щось
подібне
уявіть, що ви вчитель, і вам
потрібно допомогти мені і виправити ці речення,
добре, подивіться на це.
також деякі розділові знаки, тож
подивіться і вирішіть, що потрібно
змінити, що потрібно змінити, добре,
давайте перевіримо це разом, щоб це було так,
як ви запитали про мій улюблений
день  тижня, звичайно, це
четвер, звісно, ви повинні по
инати речення з великої літери, а д
уге речення знову з великої лі
ери, а четвер слід писати з в
ликої літери, ви знаєте, що по
еділок вівторок середа всі ці
ижні тижня починаються з великої літери  літери
англійською добре, тепер наступне одне місце,
і там написано, що в четвер ми вивчаємо французьку
англійську та хімію, деякі розділові знаки
відсутні і знову деякі великі
літери, тому подивіться, і давайте
розважимося,
ми побачимо, так що в четвер Рома ми вивчаємо
французьку кому  Англійська та хімія,
бачите, дуже цікаво, що в
англійській мові
я поділяю це з комою після четверга в
четвер кома привіт наступний після
школи ми часто ходимо до Девіда, ну
ось я бачу, що апостроф також
відсутній чи можете ви визначити, де він
Мабуть добре, хлопці, лише 10 секунд, щоб ви
подумали, і давайте подивимося, щоб після школи було написано, що
ми часто ходимо до
дому Девіда, Девід, ми, це його будинок,
я  t – присвійний відмінок, тому вам потрібно
використовувати апостроф, і знову деякі великі
літери на початку відсутні
також добре, наступний на вихідних
я відвідаю дім і бабусю, добре подумайте
, як би ви змінити це добре, щоб
ми мали  зробити так на
вихідних знову кома ти пам'ятаєш по
четвергах кома на вихідних кома тоді
я завжди з великої літери я відвідую
дідусь і бабусю
знову пропав апостроф чий
будинок мої бабуся і дідусь це
форма множини тому  вам просто потрібен
апостроф, а не тільки ' і ми, але
цей апостроф дійсно дуже
важливий, не пропускайте його добре наступний
, який ваш улюблений день тижня
знову відсутній апостроф і
відсутні деякі розділові знаки, подумайте добре,
давайте перевіримо  то який твій улюблений
день тижня, і тут з’являється знак питання,
і знову тобі потрібен апостроф,
тому що що означає те, що є, і якщо ви
використовуєте скорочення,
то вам потрібен апостроф  rophe добре
наступне речення сподіваюся почути від вас незабаром
дуже легко, так, сподіваюся почути від
вас незабаром.  сподіваюся, що
починається з великої літери, добре, і
давайте трохи обговоримо, тому, хлопці, який ваш
улюблений день тижня і чому я б
сказав, що мій улюблений день тижня -
четвер,
чому четвер четвер, безперечно,
краще, ніж неділя, тому що після неділі
настає понеділок, а після четверга  приходить
п’ятниця, і зазвичай по четвергах ми
зустрічаємося з друзями, і в нас є маленька
дитина, або ми кудись їдемо і пригощаємо
себе чимось дійсно приємним,
тому я б сказав, що мій улюблений
день тижня – четвер,
згадайте свої улюблені дні тижня,
можливо  є понеділок, коли ти зустрічаєшся
з друзями, або, можливо, вівторок,
коли у тебе є улюблені предмети, або,
можливо, середа, коли ти можеш піти
і зайнятися спортом, або четвер, якщо у
тебе така ж логіка, як у мене, можливо, їхні
п'ятниці, тому що п'ятниця у нас після
п'ятниці  у нас довгі вихідні іноді,
можливо, бувають суботи, і вони також можуть
бути напруженими днями, коли ви допомагаєте вдома
або виконуєте домашні завдання, але все одно ви
ти більш розслаблений і під час своїх робочих
днів або, можливо, є неділі, тому подумай
про свій улюблений день, тобі доведеться
написати листа, відповідаючи на ці запитання,
добре, а наступного дня, який твій найменш
улюблений день тижня і чому,
чесно кажучи, я  не можу сказати, який день тижня
мені не подобається, я повинен сказати, що я люблю
їх усіх так, і я також люблю понеділки,
тому що я люблю свою школу і я дуже
сумую за своєю гімназією плюс хлопці, я дуже
сумую за вами
, тому мені подобається  повертаючись на роботу в
понеділок, але, можливо, у вас є свої
найменш улюблені дні, подумайте про них,
і ось ваше домашнє завдання, ваше домашнє
завдання - екзаменаційне питання, а ваша
подруга Сабріна написала вам листа, в якому в
частині вказано, який ваш улюблений
день  тижня я хотів би почути все
про це і написати лист із приблизно 150
слів у відповідь 150 слів, що насправді не
так багато, якщо ви відповісте на всі
запитання, які ми мали на цьому уроці, у трьох
-чотирьох реченнях, тоді ви отримаєте
кількість слів але тих хто
готуєтеся до
ЗНО з англійської, будь ласка, будьте дуже
точними та порахуйте всі слова, хлопці, я
хочу нагадати вам про абзаци
та про великі літери про
розділові знаки та стиль
письма, будь ласка, висловлюйте свої думки, намагайтеся
бути неформальними та розважатися  якщо ви
пишете, вам не потрібно писати
правду,
ви можете уявити все, що вам подобається, це
ваша творчість і ваше письмо добре Я
сподіваюся, що ви сьогодні провели чудовий урок,
і я чекаю ваших листів, не
соромтеся розміщувати їх в Instagram або  на мою
електронну пошту, слідкуйте за оновленнями та будьте в безпеці,
до побачення
[Музика].